Nintendo visionary Hiroshi Yamauchi has died at the age of 85.
He passed away Thursday from pneumonia at a hospital in central Japan.
Yamauchi transformed Nintendo from a small card playing company into a video game giant.
He led the company for more than 50 years, serving as its CEO.
He was once the richest man in Japan with a net worth of more than five billion dollars.
He oversaw some of the most successful and revolutionary game consoles of his time.
We all remember the Super Nintendo in 1991,...
....the Game Boy, the first mainstream portable gamer, and the Nintendo 64, the first 3D console.
We'll also remember the iconic games Nintendo brought to households around the world.
Games like Super Mario, Zelda and Donkey Kong were legendary.
Not only was he famous for the games and consoles he helped pioneer,...
...but perhaps one of his greatest achievements was the N64 controller.
It was the first to include a joystick alongside buttons.
It was highly praised and became the model for future gaming consoles.
An editor for Computer and Video Games magazine said...
..."You cannot overestimate the influence the man had on the games industry."
The company said a funeral for Yamauchi will take place Sunday.
For Newsy, I'm Micah Sargent, multiple sources, a broader view.